[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight last week we noted that it seems
a little strange little odd that former
CIA director John Brennan still has a
high-level security clearance he doesn't
work for the government anymore he's a
cable news yapper who spends a lot of
his life yelling at people on Twitter
Brennan is also a political extremists
who if you listen carefully seems
unbalanced if John Brennan gets the
security clearance then why not the
homeless guy talking to himself on the
bus that seemed like a fair question
apparently the White House agreed with
that yesterday the administration
announced it is seeking to revoke
security clearances for John Brennan Jim
clapper and other former officials who
no longer work for the government
because honestly why would they have
security clearances in a normal year
that would not be a very big story but
things are not normal right now so
here's how the geniuses on cable news
reacted watch this is an abuse of
executive power this is this is Earl
wants Turkey that is exactly what you
see in authoritarian regimes it's
childish it's petty
this is so extraordinary the last thing
you want in intelligence is partisanship
that he would turn against them in a way
that obviously disrespects the civil
liberties disrespects Free Press is got
an autocratic kind of move it's the kind
of thing you'd see in a banana republic
autocratic first they came for John
Brennan's security clearance and I said
nothing barf
next time you hear some blowhard on
television warning about creeping
authoritarianism ask yourself am i for
unfettered free speech of course you are
you're an American
that is your birthright and the
foundation of all other liberties then
ask yourself a second question how about
the guy on television lecturing us about
authoritarianism is he for unfettered
free speech no chance
he considers your opinions hate speech
which is a made-up category designed to
gut the First Amendment and shut you up
he'd happily support big tech firms and
college administrators and your
company's HR department as they punish
you for saying what you think is true
creeping authoritarianism it's already
here and that guy is the face of it